Good morning I am here with John Ferrandino. I'm recording the visible
lives. John I'd like to ask you a few questions about yourself. Can you tell me
what makes you different from other individuals? Well I have like
a learning disability like I have a tough time remembering things sometimes but I'm starting
to get the hang of things, I'm
Getting better at it so. Does your disability have a classification what were
you classified as? What do you mean? Like. Learning disabled? Asperger?. What is your actual
classification for disability? Well I'm. Like I don't really have.
I have a disability but I function on those things. Well so.
Basically I. And where you from, are you from Staten Island? Well I was born
in Brooklyn, Somewhat but I moved to Staten Island when I was three.
And do you live at home? Yes.
Do you have any type of service or any
equipment or anything? What makes you able to function every day? Do you have a special computer
program or anything like that? I go to a day program at HRC.
One of my favorites. And can you tell me what you like about yourself?
Well
I'm always nice, have a lot of friends and I'm always nice to people
help them out, whatever they needed. That's
wonderful, and is there anything you dislike about yourself? No. Great.
Do you consider your life difficult, John?
Somewhat, I have ups and downs in life but I get through them.
and everyday
So. What are the things that make it difficult?
Things. Day to day. So give me a typical example of what would make a difficult
day for you. So if I had like
Like. Like for example if I have a tough time learning things I get through it
somewhat, it takes me time to get to know somebody so and then after a week when I get
to know them I get better at it.
Can you tell me who has been the most important person in your life?
It could be anybody?
Yeah, anybody.
I would have to say my longtime girlfriend Nina. Uhm I've
been with her for seven years and, she's always helped me in my life. We
hardly ever fight that much. She's very sweet and, uhm I'm looking to
hopefully like propose to her probably by the summer because I'm starting
my job in a couple weeks, so I'm hoping to buy her a ring
by the end of, by the end of the summer time hopefully to
ask her to marry me so to speak. Thats wonderful, good luck with that. Can you tell me what
important lesson Nina has taught you? Specifically? What
lessons you've learned from Nina? Well,
She's always nice and always...
So she's... her personality, she has a up... up, her personality is
contagious? Yes. It helps you? OK. I have a saying from a
famous poet. The only person you are destined to become is the person you
decide to be. Can you tell me what person you, John decided to be?
Uhm, I decided to be
a nice person,
and like calm in situations,
and always work hard for myself.
So. Thats awesome. I'd like you to finish this sentence. I draw my strength
from... What makes you strong?
Family and friends. Great answer.
Tell me lastly what would you like people to know about individuals like yourself?
That are diagnosed with learning disorders or uhm
same type of developmental issues that you have. What would you like people to learn?
Well, like
Like peoples to learn that uhm, what do you mean like?
Well, for instance what lesson would you like society to know about
individuals like yourself that attend day [re]hab programs, that struggle with a disability,
Uhm what lesson is there? For them so to speak?
Yes. Uhm, to be strong and always do your thing.
That's awesome.
Thank you so much for sharing your story with me at Public Library. It's going to be
preserved for other people to learn your valuable lesson. Mhm. Thank you
so much for sitting and speaking with me today.